hey guys so let me explain what i'm
doing in this video real quick so i'm
using a glitch known as the pegasus
glitch where you can glitch out torrent
and you can make them fly at a certain
height throughout the entire map of
elden ring what i was curious of doing
with this glitch was what would happen
if i went to the end of ronnie's
questline because we know that the end
of her questline ends at the cathedral
of manicellus so what would happen if i
just flew there and just went down in
the hole she's in i was very curious if
she was actually down there and if i
needed the ring at all to give to her
and what actually happens is surprising
enjoy the video guys what's funny with
this and i'm really curious of so this
is basically skipping her entire
questline right like i'm here at level
frickin
26 haven't done any of her quest line i
haven't even gone to her side of the map
like at all very curious if we go down
into the hole
if she's there and you can get the
moonville or the the darkmoon greatsword
without doing any of the questline like
i wonder if the button prompt for
offering her the ring
is still an option even though we do not
have it
i'm gonna go ahead and guess that she's
not down there
i like maybe that bloody doll is and
maybe the the two fingers is down there
as well
but i don't know about about ronnie
being down there i i don't know we about
to find out okay we can come around the
side here
uh if i can touch ground
please okay there we go
you have to touch ground for that to
work okay let's not fall to our death
this time this is really breaking the
game here if she's over here i'd be very
surprised
she is here
this character model is always just here
no way i can offer the ring though right
it's just it's just prompted you don't
have to have the ring at all
oh my god we could actually do
we just skipped all of randy's questline
the entire thing that's awesome
absolutely incredible so
this body doll is always down here
and if you just enter into the room
the the ring prompt is always there
or the giving her the ring is always an
option we never got that ring
we're just here doing it
hi ronnie i've never met you before how
are you
oh it was me
i've never
heck yeah
do i get the great sword give me the
great sword
yes
oh
my god actually crazy
skipped
everything and got all the rewards
let's go